rubber baby baby baby baby to the
beep-beep in secret lab but subscribed
and man with an iron hand Marvel's dusty
studios hello my name is Tiger ygg
director actor
welcome to thor ragnarok hi guess humor
it's so particular and unique and quirky
all of these tiny little things hanging
washing on electrical cables that's
exactly what we do on earth I'm into the
story it's an asset working with tyka
involves hijinks dancing days just a big
kid we like that the whole time college
is cracking up on staff and staff later
the most light-hearted fun set I've been
on Oh
scrapple 142 to 114 tooth scrapper look
at this world of amazement yes through
this door top Australia
as a Korean Radio Shack carryin Walkman
the Korean iPod the Korean Plumbing
Supplies still just Li like if plumbing
supplies
that is how you make movies she's coming
who are you talking about
your sister you're in my seat I don't
want to fight your sister that's a
family issue I'm putting together a team
you me and the big guy named Skoll D
here revenge's revenge
Wow I didn't hear any thunder but out of
your fingers was that like sparkles
the revolution has become
but is saying yes Hulk like fire door
like water